if you've already watched the now emmy
nominated watchmen here are five other
titles for you to check out on this
week's bench guide
hbo's watchmen dominated the 70-second
prime time emmy awards nominations with
26 total noms including limited series
and
six different acting nominations for
stars like regina king
and jeremy irons and since it looks like
this show that's based in the same
universe of the popular graphic novel
is not coming back and you've already
seen the 2009 movie
maybe you can try binging these starting
with our throwback pick the leftovers
this mysterious hbo show aired for three
seasons starting in 2014 and is from
creator damon lindelof the man behind
not only watchmen but also lost
with a cast that includes stars like
justin throw amy brennaman
and watchman's regina king follows a
small community coping with life three
years after
two percent of the world's population
vanished you can binge this what critics
call
an artfully crafted thought-provoking
drama in about 28 hours but you can
only choose two percent of your friends
to share it with moving on to our
editor's pick this week it is marvel's
jessica jones
with three fresh seasons this netflix
drama stars kristen ritter as a ptsd
stricken superhero who hangs up her
costume and opens her
own detective agency with a supporting
cast that includes carrie anne moss and
rachel taylor plus mike culture's luke
cage papanin
critics call this a multifaceted drama
that's built around its engaging
anti-hero
the third and final season wrapped up
last year bringing the total bench time
to just over 36 hours for what has been
considered one of marvel's strongest tv
franchises next up is our under the
radar pick and that's going to amc's
drama
creature this one is based on the comic
book series of the same name and follows
a minister who teams up with his ex
and a hard drinking irish vampire after
he gains supernatural powers
it was co-created by seth rogen and evan
goldberg the same team that's partly
behind amazon to the boys
and stars dominic cooper and ruth nega
and if you're not already sold critics
call this visually stunning adaptation
a thrilling celebration of the bazaar
you can binge
all four seasons in about 43 hours and
it'll be even more fun if you invite
your ex and a hard drinking irish
vampire
to join you and for our brand new pick
this week we've hunted down
amazon's hunters which debuted in
february from executive producer jordan
peel this drama follows a ragtag team of
nazi hunters in 1977 new york city
critics say that the stylish first
season is propelled by a strong cast
that includes al pacino
logan lerman and jerica hinton and an
even stronger sense of justice
no word yet on a second season for
hunters but you can binge the first one
in about 10 hours complete with all the
glorious 70s cars and fashion that you
can handle
and finally our certified fresh pick
this week is legion
this sci-fi drama from fx ran for three
straight certified fresh seasons
and is about a diagnosed schizophrenic
played by dan stevens who discovers
special powers that change his life
forever
the cast also includes watchmen's gene
smart who just picked up an emmy
nomination for supporting actress
and critics call legion a singular piece
of visually arresting mind-bending
television that never fails to surprise
you can binge all three seasons in
around 27 hours and keep an ear out for
the heavy influence of pink floyd used
by show creator
noah holly all right friends hopefully
this will make you a very happy watch
person for your next few bench sessions
be sure to let us know what you are
currently streaming in the comments
and don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and notification bell so you
don't miss out on any future
recommendations based around the movies
and shows that you love
right here on the rotten tomatoes binge
guide thank you so much for watching
this video
and we'll see you guys next time bye
you